oh [ __ ] we got movement off you old fool
this with your [ __ ] [ __ ] oh this
[ __ ] is brutal right here [ __ ]
out of it like you [ __ ] little
Gentile smoke on wet we we just market
competition not either yeah this is what
a [ __ ] cop on that exercise Hill exam
I know it yeah yeah
yeah we went [ __ ] around tonight yeah
we got some trim I mean [ __ ] killer
we check this out [ __ ] I don't
even know what it is don't matter dad
you understand me I got it by one
o'clock and I put in a bag and I put it
in my wife's car beaming on the hundred
and thirteen degree weather you
understand me this thing is like a
[ __ ] pallet the weed stores trying to
tell you the wheat they sell you the
weed wet so the weight and then you
[ __ ] you know I don't smoke weed
that's for [ __ ] amateurs I smoke weed
that's nice and dry you get the full
[ __ ] but y-you understand me
that's why but these [ __ ] say
you're wet we'd have to smokin dry weeds
just a [ __ ] ad shack you know exactly
where you stand you're following me
decent wait this is the way [ __ ]
professionals do it I don't give a [ __ ]
how the rest of these mooks the mooks
don't
this is uncle Joey coming at you on the
[ __ ] Lord's Day Sabbath bloody
Sabbath the church the flying Jew and
don't [ __ ] matter it's on tonight
[ __ ]
just like that you understand me whether
don't stop them at the [ __ ] the mailman
I smoke in every weather hail sleet
extreme [ __ ] heat and don't matter
uncle Joey shows up and weed starts - we
don't [ __ ] around you understand it's
Sunday you want to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] -
come back on Tuesday ok it's the Lord's
Day and God don't like [ __ ] [ __ ] so
get your [ __ ] together we only got to
open up let's say tonight milligram wise
oh sorry about that my [ __ ] swipe
through I got this [ __ ] Puerto Rican
tripod here what are you gonna do so we
got six stars there's 200 go edit go
there [ __ ] freak oh we're gonna open
up with these mmm just to open up
opening up with 600 as an appetizer on
the [ __ ] purple ones cuz that county
row these little blood [ __ ]
[ __ ] and [ __ ] you up daddy
it never ends
nice nice and [ __ ] dry what if we
went for a [ __ ] father sauce keep
that [ __ ] we oh this is [ __ ] clean
Bobby but look what we got in the backup
enzyme we'll throw a couple leaves in
there just to get the two different Reds
in the mix Simpson please tell me I'm in
training I think that these tines of
follow this is nothing this is an
opening up what is believe
two weeks alone beef every day with
sugar nut biscuits there's no 600 you
ain't no 606 last week that was the
night even a [ __ ] Starla [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] anyway you see you all
week tell them what happens when you see
a one night a week just torture yes it
sport you you just send them that gross
[ __ ] out of it refuel go back [ __ ]
Adam understand me spend three hours
like a be [ __ ] choking you to death
you know saying you said you only have
sex five times a night
you see you're the one that's a that's
great that don't mix them with the
[ __ ] stars and goes down nice and
easy the THC smoked wings so that either
you don't wait a little bit there you
don't need to figure this up you bad
[ __ ] you look at all [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are you doing with your life
[ __ ] so that's 600 that's 725
that's 250 and 600 is 850 you know this
man over here regurgitate that [ __ ]
you like crepe this is so low like this
strong but like you're fat do with the
[ __ ] sleeves you have to eat your food
[ __ ] drive
no [ __ ] nuttin look at 8:15 this
which one more 975 [ __ ] it will be
looking fillet you're gonna have to just
watch and see if we pop that last
[ __ ] stock to make it nine hundred
and fifty milligrams happy Father's Day
to all you bad [ __ ] out there
Uncle Joe he loves you with all his
[ __ ] heart for all the [ __ ] and the
struggle yeah I'm saying I love you
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] with you
[ __ ] you know it's especially now
because their feelings hurt war [ __ ]
head boats we live to [ __ ] swing dick
another day
and that's it what you with all things
you go see your dad at your barbecue
there was 113 [ __ ] degrees in it
nobody was barbecuing dick pizza
delivery boys are going crazy tonight
[ __ ]
we're going deep with Sabbath bloody
Sabbath we're waiting on my man Nick
gregarious BJJ Brotherhood dropping it
tonight gonna come by and say hello you
got me my friend Lisa why should we do
another stop when we got now 851 won't
put us at 975 creeping on the devil's
door we're knocking on the door
good cosplay had a good time my daughter
it was really like my official first
Father's Day everybody saying last year
mercy was - she don't [ __ ] know about
fathers dad who's a [ __ ] father but
now we have a good day today my wife
better go look at houses - [ __ ]
naturally that's how tired I am
between the [ __ ] heat and the mental
[ __ ] dealing with you [ __ ]
right jokes doing spots in podcast it
gets old last night's and I was giving
it be [ __ ] call them like listen bro
in my world now the other side you out
of - too much chicken no offense
it's so [ __ ] with my main man what's
his name Jordan Lee I didn't see him for
two months think about [ __ ] joy I
love them there's so much [ __ ] in gonna
your face don't even know treat your
life but what it's worth and therefore
as we friend
what here we go constantly looking back
I've lived in love and now I'm wondering
sitting there thinking to yourself what
am I gonna do with my life I'm looking
at a window it's 2,000 [ __ ] degrees I
got no air conditioning these mosquitos
are killing me right
answer the phone come here is [ __ ] can't
happen here I can't have nine people
here so suck up all the [ __ ] call
this
the more people the less gold a tumblr
man and that's it
it's the Lord's Day you thinking what
I'm gonna do what I'm feeling like 60
minutes as Lamech State shooting people
you got game [ __ ] seven folly over by
now
I don't mean to be a [ __ ] spoiler
wow-wow in Golden State will slow that
coming like I tell you [ __ ] you
never saw puppy with a part-time job you
understand
you never see a bookie with a part-time
job man in business police even their
mother had gone to state for the series
the Prince of Darkness Timmy Holloway
let's sit beautiful people have another
weak and funny I go to Philadelphia this
week the City of Brotherly Love
Philadelphia freedom Elton John [ __ ]
everything I'm excited now I'm done with
cheese Facebook 53 is on the cheese
station eat before you die cheesesteaks
I'm gonna cheese take down the Quan I go
for stuff I can't have here nice egg
roll a nice twice cooked pork with
steamed rice with some [ __ ] real dump
there's your pizza
you know me I keep it like this right by
right by the hotel is a nice little
steak house got a lunch special you know
me will SAP a little steak a little
baked potato some lunch special I come
from I live for lunch specials live for
lunch special especially now
I like the big meal the second meal with
a dent so I could bring some [ __ ] off at
night and stuff it's not bad man a good
lunch special bowl of soup maybe an egg
roll something fried shrimp you know you
don't need to do much fungal Joey
bring the [ __ ] dry noodles with the
soup because that's part of the meal
right that's hope father that's why you
get your main course and steamed rice
and I said I'm happy a fortune cookie
I'm whistling down the [ __ ]
mice are in slices say that deal with
the main course you don't use on your
own time hang on the street the orange
after you had that [ __ ] Xena lose the
taste that's the [ __ ] taste you still
see bag of clams at the airport would
say you buy a $12 suitcase
and going into the Apple no leaks you
can even bring a cooler with live clams
just did it for me that always works
like all these color they're not gonna
bring back soon as you get off the
[ __ ] plane by the raw clams land soon
as you get off the plane you get off the
plane at 9:00 right run right the house
take a shot wash your [ __ ] and get them
boiling
we'll be over at 11:30 just laid a case
of Corona a few [ __ ] numbers
following link you just gotta talk
believe from the heart here can't be
bringing back the lien brownies with no
[ __ ]
nuts known where you go you get some
nice [ __ ] lobster tails at the bakery
with the claimant of you somehow gonna
waste my [ __ ] luggage space with
[ __ ] brownies is easy it infuriates
pastry ones yeah six lots of tails
koalas [ __ ] ass olive oil you just
give it to me you see I'm taking yours
your [ __ ] I say somebody's [ __ ] in
your mouth
that's a [ __ ] proudly you look at
Brandi Lee did someone [ __ ] my mouth
what am I doing here
if I eat a brownie wants a [ __ ] it
I'm happy always as I was a kilogram
that's diligent tight stomach i lobster
tail a nice [ __ ] strawberry shortcake
Jewish made with the [ __ ] game plan
this speaking ins bakery those Jews were
[ __ ] notorious for like [ __ ] I'm
thinking let me tell you something that
strawberry shortcake those lobster tails
never [ __ ] them those little black
and white cookies that's what you been
back never
brownies that's for some guy named John
Smith I have brought your brownies what
get the [ __ ] off my front doorstep next
time you [ __ ] know show up for a pie
and ice cream my house comes back
before you think about that [ __ ]
are you smoking are you token
are you eating slaw as a debt to eat the
last [ __ ] star put us ignore time
enough 7:40 so anyway what Sunday what
what sir this day the 19th my 25th
anniversary economy went great I did a
show in a [ __ ] place I had no air
conditioning but I don't give a [ __ ] me
and Tommy used to got to look up we saw
Willie Barcena
it was beautiful you bad [ __ ]
Cleveland won the championship I'd love
to congratulate them I think that
[ __ ] definitely got a little bit too
spoiled
I think it's little bit of a baby I
think it came back to haunt them in the
end I feel bad for his teammates they're
[ __ ] savages what are you gonna do
what do you how does it make your life
different who wins the game but it
doesn't it doesn't it really doesn't you
get down for two seconds when you're ten
you know what am I lollipop yeah when
you're ten you get the press like a
second my team goes away I see it don't
like this [ __ ] Jamal
the Stalin wants to get they get enough
but when you give a [ __ ] I'm listed damn
watching one support mix [ __ ] there no
livin on the Lord's Day something
there's somebody a church for a half a
mil in their pocket you try to mug it
cuz I'm sayin
that can't happen get the [ __ ] out there
nothing happens on the counts [ __ ]
they sit there what does it say on my
iPad we should play Warcraft oh yeah
watch lost 15 episodes like an [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] about nothing
especially that [ __ ]
good purpose a few years ago right
purple orange isn't funny
six lesbians in gym that's what I gotta
watch in this day and this day of
[ __ ] time I gotta watch list six
lesbians in the jail I'm gonna dump I
don't mind seeing lesbians with guns
shooting [ __ ] neck
I don't know I never really thought of
lesbian program
I got 850 milligrams of pure THC running
through my veins you think I'm thinking
about lesbian program what's my I love
lesbians doesn't sad in like lesbians
that's at the point the point is I never
know what I want to watch on TV every
view of always be you take the chubby
one to protect you on their ankles
you're looking for long lease I at I'll
give me his number tomorrow you call
this [ __ ] the rent but throw your
27 knew that where's my life goal people
you have any [ __ ] idea right straight
the pleats a little absolute [ __ ] go
I was my house glasses
I can't find them no what if I throw
them away that means a little [ __ ]
psyche I just get me black little
photometers psychiatry classes [ __ ]
people
there were like 400 for [ __ ] glasses
with these [ __ ] but these friends
are they think it makes them more
[ __ ] intelligent two [ __ ] three
idiots [ __ ] with glasses on
it drives me [ __ ] nuts when I said
the comedy star gotta get it they got a
go they got a go with those glasses
straight that type of comedy context
don't give a [ __ ] you didn't nobody know
now I got to [ __ ] blind
this is my left eye I can look through a
wall and see it's thick enough hang up
the [ __ ]
but my right eye is slipping that's why
my head's always tilted because I kind
of zero
f1 that's why you got a little tilt I'll
give you the eye of debt I'm Sam
joy what's it the chitty-chat your spark
up the number why not before we flip
over the side to killing yourself to
live a [ __ ] tremendous song
I'm a man give me the sound Kevin
that's it that's a doctor police puffs
right dick [ __ ]
that's from inside the [ __ ] diaphragm
you see that maybe since we had dr.
police on I don't smoke as much back cuz
I'm getting them more for my bang from
the reason cuz it goes deep into my
diaphragm into my stomach and I blow the
cloud of [ __ ] debt that so you know
we got till they cut suckers you start
getting the pin you sitting there like a
Swami from some money let's see we got
we got that's Usama we got blue apron
and honey that's what we got this [ __ ]
you like me with the [ __ ] glasses
check out hmm
I've been doing my CBD oil I got the guy
coming on the show next week with some
vapor dude and that's it people you were
just sitting there like a [ __ ] bump
on a lot so what uncle joy came into
your life now at least we're having a
conversation you were sitting there
staring around you know you're gonna do
it your life will smoke a ball will sit
back when this to the church you might
learn a thing or two or maybe not you
might laugh you might not and I'm saying
but at least you're through doing
something out of the [ __ ] box Wonder
Woman is still it's gotta be at least
100 [ __ ] degrees but we got a little
semblance and ham it's nice and cool
110 where you gonna beat them on I got a
short day - mom I'm doing jiu-jitsu it
11 o'clock well that's it there's gonna
be [ __ ] hot - give me a couple
dollars we'll give you a gig and I'll
give you a hundred bucks if you want to
be 10 to 11 with the gear on with a hood
on yeah all right I'll be there
North Hollywood [ __ ] 10 a.m. tomorrow
Lee's on the walk around I gotta get the
house as I pull up listen this
[ __ ] by the second lap is gonna
be passed the [ __ ] out you understand I
guarantee that first one we give them a
few stars you know about that one
and we'll get John the heat exhaustion
now you'll die yeah
tomorrow you'll die that Park North
Hollywood Park it's a really weird thing
it's like uh I'm thinking New Jersey the
thing is to call [ __ ] bill will next
the [ __ ] though there's a [ __ ] well
there's a town I sorta got [ __ ] bills
like little houses midgets with dead and
right next to it there's a hill that you
could park your car on neutral and your
car get pulled up the hill it's like
some type of gap I'm not a scientist I
don't know what the [ __ ] to describe is
but you go to North Hollywood Park -
well about four o'clock oh that's the
hottest that park would be the corner on
the right and the sun is shining on it
it'll still be so cool under there and
you won't understand why it's like a
[ __ ] scientific freak if you walk
around in the mornings you'll see people
stop down there breathing heavy from
jogging because it's cooler down there
it's right it's maybe that someone go
see if he's up there
we should be out there there's a car
maybe a four foot drop and right there
you just children decide by that
[ __ ] we gotta fix this [ __ ] we
gotta fix it we gotta push that air to
refrigerate it closer to there I think
we'll figure out see if he's out to
anybody's out there I'm gonna get this
party started sorry ladies and gentlemen
you know I love you guys are all my
heart we're about to start the show you
me about ten minutes
stay black was smoking for you concepts
I'm telling you there may be me nobody
else will tell you open your eyes and
see them oh yeah here we go
are you [ __ ] kidding me or what have
you got a syringe pop that smoke yet
get it [ __ ] I will be back now
stay black uncle Joey loves you usually
those eyes look at them already closed